joining us now author of the soon-to-be
best-selling book vengeance just out
last week former Speaker of the House
Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich I
know you're aware of this uranium one
deal and now we've got documents we've
got emails we've got financial records
we've got eyewitnesses that show they
knew the Obama administration knew in
2009 about Russia top officials bribery
kickbacks extortion of money laundering
and they still signed off on the uranium
one deal 20% of our uranium in the hands
of Russia and keep in mind the same
Russia that they've been screaming about
for a year your thoughts on this
development well I say first of all the
best news I heard tonight was your
report the senator grassley is beginning
to ask very serious questions and I hope
that the Senate Judiciary Committee is
going to open a full-blown investigation
I also hope the chairman Goodlatte in
the house and the house did it shake
that he will do the same these are
unbelievable charges you know if this is
true for under their two fronts here
there's the Russian front which is
unbelievable and there's the Comey
drafting an exoneration of Hillary two
months before an interview dur now both
of those indicate levels of corruption
and dishonesty on a scale that I can't
remember in American history I mean this
whole thing coming together right now in
the way it's coming together the people
who were involved I mean if I think the
average American is going to demand that
the House and Senate hold full-blown
clear public hearings put this stuff on
the record I want to see the draft
versions of what Comey was writing two
months before you know we have it but
yeah there's no wonder that didn't put
her yeah it's unbelievable signed sealed
delivered exoneration doesn't matter you
mishandled classified information
destroyed classified information and you
destroy subpoenaed emails why do I think
I'd be in jail and you'd be calling me
on the phone on Saturday night well I
mean think about if you're Senator Bob
Menendez and you're you're being tried
for something and you suddenly learn
that what the Clintons did
maybe fifty to a hundred times bigger
and involved national security with
Russia and there nothing happening to
him I mean if I was Mendez I think wow
talk about justice not being fair and
then you look at Comey who is this great
virtuous person in the Washington press
corps you start saying wait a second
he's writing an exoneration two months
before you interview sir no wonder they
didn't put her under oath
never mind that that scene was rigged
all the media Department and Democratic
politicians they quoted the dossier that
they used Russian sources for this is
where the media in this in this country
hurts the American people because they
don't do their job their agenda-driven
they run they've made more mistakes in
the last year than I've ever seen it and
I thought it was bad when you was
Speaker
I got a transition I got to ask you
about this how important this tax deal
is how important that Cochran who is not
feeling well flew back for this thing
McCain you never know what the hell he's
gonna do I mean he's just
flighty as all can be lately this is
look I think the president was exactly
right tonight I think Speaker Paul Ryan
has sent out a note saying for the
average working American it's only a
four thousand dollar increase in
take-home pay work that Kevin Hassett
counselor the chair of the Council of
Economic Advisers have put together four
thousand dollars per family I wouldn't
be at all surprised to see some
Democrats decide that they're going to
vote for this thing this is the key to
the year for the Congress and for the
President and it has to be done this
year president's way of putting it yeah
I love the way the president put it
tonight it ought to be a Christmas gift
for every American it'll really get the
economy rolling and nothing can be more
important for the Republicans than to
focus on getting this done and getting
it signed
I would prefer before Thanksgiving but
certainly in early December by the way
it is personal with John McCain when he
came back after his surgery he did say
to stop listening to radio and cable
hosts like me and people like me can go
straight to hell
but I didn't take it personally at all I
want to this is important the end of the
year because the time
line is now tough because the house is
on vacation this week the Senate was on
vacation last week who takes this much
vacation which is a side note are you
confident that at the end of the day the
McCain's
the Susan Collins's those that voted for
the that are voting for this bill are
the they got to be there are they gonna
be Republicans for once are they gonna
get their identity somewhat back or
they're gonna bail and screw it up like
health care no I look I think you know
your first real test this week if they
can pass the budget resolution this week
that's a huge step in the right
direction I also think they may have a
little bit of luck in that I do think
there are three or four Democrats I mean
you start if we can drive home for small
businesses what a huge tax break it is
for working middle-class Americans what
a huge tax break it is you know you go
out to North Dakota you go to Montana
you go to Missouri you go to Indiana
those are all Democratic seats in West
Virginia and you're talking about a
$4,000 increase per middle-class family
now I think it's gonna be pretty tough
for the Democrats to go home and vote no
I
I saw your comments about Steve battered
and yeah I think I don't want to see the
Democrats take over the House or Senate
but I'm with Steve man and in this sense
that if Mitch McConnell can't get the
job done Mitch McConnell needs to go he
is not getting the job done and for him
saying oh we have excessive expectations
well our expectations were raised
because I see you laughing were raised
because people like him were promising
to repeal and replace health care for
seven years and they couldn't get their
rack together all right go ahead
straighten me out go ahead I'm not gonna
straighten you out I want to say look
you just have made a different case than
Boehner made would I respond to two with
Bannen as he said he was gonna run
against every Republican except Ted Cruz
Ted Cruz up for reelection shall we go
down the list everybody he's talking
about voted to repeal Obamacare
everybody's talking about it's going to
vote to cut taxes everybody's talking
about voted for every single Trump judge
show me the principal case for trimming
I don't mind if he wants to complain
about
Mitch Mitch is a big boy he'll take care
of himself but that's not the argument
here Bannon is suggesting and he says it
himself he's gonna wage war against two
against Republicans you know when we
fought Nazi generally we didn't start by
trying to fight Britain talking about a
real war it means the art of political
war and it's obviously every wait a
second Sean yeah wait no wait a second
we're good friends we'll hold on
Erica Hannon said against every
Republican senator except Cruz did I
think that is an absurdity okay here's
what I want I want Republicans I wish I
could say what I'm thinking to get their
bleep together and do their job and I
think Steve Madden saying the same thing
they have really screwed up not they
have really screwed up in the last nine
months of this year yes seven and a half
year promises pretty disappoint us go
ahead too good at this to death say that
he said a specific thought I'm reacting
to a specific thing I'm assuming Bannon
who I and you and I both know well yeah
I'm assuming abandon about what he said
he said he's going to run against every
senator except Cruz I think that's
absurd and if you go check that my
column on Friday is going to be about
this you check their records they voted
for every point judge the only they I
would say repeal Obamacare politicians
seem to respond to one thing fear of
losing their power and I think Alabama
was a was a shot across the bow the
canary in the coal mine
they don't organize and get together and
get in a room and shut the door and turn
off the air conditioning like our
framers and founders and I'll even send
them free pizza which didn't exist for
them and get on the same page and serve
the American people the Forgotten men
and women fear seems to be a good
motivator and I think Bannon is saying
get your act together and I agree with
that sentiment Oh get your act the
others fine trying to beat all the
Republicans that I think is just dumb we
never want to debate some night about it
if you want to invite Steve on I'll be
one I'll come on with Steve all right
we'll do an out I'd do an hour with you
and Steve any day I think it's important
I really do
all right that'll be fun it'll be quite
an evening congratulate all right I'll
set it up I'll call him right after the
show
good to see you congratulations on the
new book